foreign
[Music]
I love this all right I like the
conference hang on wait wait wait
oh come on put all that in here
you're gonna carry all my stuff okay
wait wait
you looking for a pity
exactly what I'm looking for
oh my friend
you ready
and go
everybody
[Music]
I'm guessing you work out
are you okay
oh yeah
drum roll please
the woman of my dreams is in
London England oh London the lady in the
Mist no one calls it that the gray lady
no that's New York Times uh yeah sure
y'alls she does travel a lot for work
there you go that makes sense she
probably got called away last minute on
this job and had a rush over there you
know international calling plans and
whatnot I bet she hasn't even seen your
text yeah yeah yeah that makes sense
okay exactly okay so this is fine
absolutely
what
yeah something we can tell our
grandchildren mom you can't be serious
Cole going to London no why not this is
the perfect opportunity to get out there
and grab Life by the horns she's gonna
think that you're psycho or she'll think
that I'm the kind of guy that's willing
to jump on a plane at a moment's notice
wait but you're not that kind of guy you
do not travel anywhere you haven't left
the country that's not true he was
conceived in Ontario Nicole you can do
this yeah but what about the farm
there's so much to do I can't just leave
you coleslaw don't worry about the farm
buy the horns come on yeah go to her
you're a liar
I'm not the liar here
I told you things I've never told anyone
it was all true
not all of it
okay one lie about my job
I really ate it up too didn't I
especially that sob story about your
co-worker that died that is low
that was actually true her name was
Elena
and she really died
I may have killed her
what
she was an enemy agent
she worked for these guys you said she
was a co-worker she was an elusive see
this is what I'm talking about it's just
lies and lies and more lies are more
lies it's the sublight of the first
original life you're unbelievable
hey
fine I lied about my job but you lied
about who you are well excuse me for
fudging a few details to try and impress
the most amazing woman I've ever met
oh god seriously you know I'm trying to
connect about a person that just died
someone you knew well are you capable of
that or is that only on first dates the
rest of the time it's just chemical
weapons and passcodes and bullets and
death wait what passcodes what do you
mean about passcodes the Bug Guy in the
cave kept
asking me about passcodes
he thinks I have the passcode yeah and
you're telling me this now oh I'm sorry
I was slightly drugged and kidnapped at
the time also in case you forgot I'm a
farmer I'm not a super spy why didn't
you just ask me what the torturer was
torturing me about you are unbelievable
what what what are the passcodes
the least you could do is tell me what I
almost died for
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
I was just wondering if you wanted to um
you know go out sometime you want to get
a coffee now yes now
I'll just hang on
[Music]
I mean I know this sounds crazy but I
think she might be the one
who goes along with you she really is
great you'll see
any word
she goes to them I bet she hasn't even
seen your text she does travel a lot for
work go to her I'm going to London
so you get it it's a grand romantic
gesture that is amazing mate 5 000 miles
as far as a girl you've only met once
especially if she's the one who ghosted
yeah
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan oh right
[Music]
where am I oh God you have the wrong guy
I'm a former wait wait
can you walk goal
who are you CIA
I'm so confused they kept asking me
about the tax man they asked you about
the tax man didn't think I am attachment
George attacks man oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I saw the rock
you're the one who flew to London
it was a romantic gesture
get three bumpy Hunts on the continent I
want her life
Mr Speaker than you and me
oh
I'd never occur to you that he could be
a foreign asset trying to compromise
your mission
who the hell are you
I'm the boyfriend
[Music]
do you trust me is that a joke
thank you
[Music]